nous retrouvons notre correspondant à
Kiev gulverer Kra gulverer bonjour Que
dit Kiev sur ces accusations
russes alors l'état-major ukrainien euh
parle du fait que il cible souvent ce
territoire autour de Belgorod en Russie
non pas tant en réplique au bombardement
russse de l'Ukraine mais pour essayer de
empêcher la Russie de bombarder harkiv
et récemment ils ont fait cela en
utilisant des missiles ballistiques de
type S300 et dans son communiqué
l'état-major parle de ces tentative
d'éliminer ces systèmes de missile vous
l'aurez peut-être noté il ne niit pas
avoir abattu l'avion mais il ne
l'admettent pas non plus d'autres
sources militaires ukrainiens ont dit
sous conditions d'anonymat aux médias
Ukrainiens que ils observaient
exactement ce même avion transportter
des roquettes et des pièces pour ces
systèmes de missile ballistique S300
plusôt dans la journée d'hier des
sources avaient dit qu'il y avait des
roquettes à bord de l'avion maintenant
des experts en explosive en aviation
disent que la manière dont l'avion a
explosé ne semble pas indiquer qu'il y
avait une grande quantité d'explosiv à
bord mais peut-être qu'il y avait
d'autres pièces pour l'avion on ne sait
pas c'est ce que je pense tout le monde
en Ukraine espère parce que ils espèrent
découvrir que ce n'était pas vrai que il
y avait ces prisonniers de guerre
Ukrainiens à bord de l'avion en tout cas
officiellement pour le moment les
renseignements militaires Ukrainiens se
limitent à dire qu'un échange devait
avoir lieu mais qu'il ne peuvent pas
confirmer que les prisonniers étaient
transportés dans cet avion les Russes
n'avaient pas dit au côté ukrainien que
les prisonniers étaient transportés dans
cet avion comme pour les échanges de
prisonniers précédents il il l'avait
fait il y a aussi des informations comme
quoi le le nombre total de prisonniers à
échangé hier qui devait faire partie de
cet échange qui n'a pas eu lieu était de
1912 ce qui pose la question alors
pourquoi il n'y avait que 65 dans
l'avion qui a une capacité bien plus
grande ce qui alimente les espoirs ici à
Kiev que que les Russes encore une fois
mentent sur cette question merci
beaucoup gulivard krack depuis kiief
j'ajoute que le président zelanski a
demandé l'ouverture d'une enquête
internationale pour faire la lumière sur
ces événements on l'a compris autour
duquel il y a encore beaucoup de flou il
est